[Music]
first eight hours of playing a beta was
a major concern there's a lot to talk
about with this stuff so for those of
you who don't know how this system works
and well this is again speaking on the
beta right
we do not know necessarily what the
final product is gonna look like however
but this you're willing to bet that this
is pretty much like oh this off like
what six months ago as well
yeah right about this before yeah so
like what's gonna change or basically
like you know balancing and what comes
in a crate but this isn't grain into the
gameplay this is how it works this is
how you progress in this game is by
opening crates how it works is there are
different rarities associated with
crates excuse me just star cards or you
get out of them we have we do not know
and that's another thing that I'll talk
about later we do not know what these
crates what other forms they'll take
like I've heard rumors that there are
crates specific to classes so there are
four classes if I want you know if I
want to focus on a specialist class I
can get the specialist crate and be
guaranteed one star card as of the beta
now yeah you get three in each one
different levels of rarity like uncommon
common epic Legendary's Legendary's this
is the kicker legendary star cards you
can only get in a loot crate there's
another way you can progress more or
less is with sorry is with crafting
parts crafting parts I can get from blue
crates or I can get them through career
which is on the top menus their career
is basically like your challenges for
it's like kill 250 enemies in a galactic
conquest map and get 20 credits points
the then my first frustration when I was
playing after eight hours was that I had
880 crafting points I said to my I set a
goal and as far as the Qureshi my
progression I was like you know what
I like The Specials class I want to put
a scope on the rifle of this weapon well
I was still unable to do that because
that crafting part costs 100 crafting
parts 8 hours in I was unable to do my
own my own challenge you know what I
mean like my own form of lighting a
scope on a gun putting out a goddamn
scope on it that's gone I was not able
to do that within eight hours hour one
like this is like outrageous notice and
I am it and this is yeah and this is one
scope on one gun for a class like that
that made like Peter I remember texting
you late at night I was really
frustrated with that because what is
happening is you're getting credits from
after matches which are not actually
dependent on your skill so if someone
kicks ass if someone plays like garbage
you're most part getting the same amount
of credits but you're opening crates man
you're opening up fairly often and what
you getting in these crates well as of
the beta you're getting like so many
times I was getting freaking emotes for
like Ray or Boba Fett dude I can't I've
never been once and then the game ended
like its it's just most the time you're
just getting [ __ ] there was one time I'm
sorry because it just didn't give you
what it promised that was once exact you
took the words on the mouth one time I
was like because I there I will say a
lot of things about this beta this the
the Starfighter mode is freaking awesome
either like I just this morning I played
some more of it before it ended I like I
really like that mode I really do yet
there is a Starfighter create I open
that up guess what I was supposed to be
guaranteed didn't get a single
Starfighter card it was like these
things she was just copies it was like
nothing that it was promised granted
that's beta but that's annoying I'm
annoyed if like if I have to lay there
are two ways for me to progress right
either I luck out with a loot crate or I
use crafting parts and
said Luke rate didn't even offer what it
what it said in the beta and will point
you to spend money what that's dude
that's the foot that's the [ __ ]
question because here's the thing I will
lose my mind and I guarantee it I will I
will lose my goddamn I'm are already
losing it if there are legendary blue
crates guarantee legendary Luke racer
which I think there will be that is
that's messed up that is them that is
the most aggressive like mobile game the
crate system I've ever heard
apologies if you've said this already
but didn't don't you say when people
kill you it shows what they had equipped
so damn right does so like hey why would
they do that that's just gonna make you
feel like we [ __ ] more cards dude but
right and then yeah that's the thing
like they're just trying to like lure
you into it like that guy just killed
you with this ability so why not go buy
this and it's there's so many things
that were racing from through my head
that one night where I was pressure I
was like you know I'm thinking about
it's Star Wars right think about the
audience that that franchise has just
locked their our guarantee going to be
12 year old kids who have maybe access
to their parents card who you know it's
just it is you for crush when you open
one of those things up and you get
something sick I did happen to me I was
like sick my bomber my bombers health
now is like real great where his like
damage output is really awesome now like
that's a rush and you're you're
consistently doing that [ __ ] and you
have to you have to that's another thing
I hope they fix is you like you can't do
that in between rounds I have to legit
leave the the game and go into this damn
menu open it up put it on like upgrade
if I want I don't know it's just like
similar issues of destiny I have yeah no
that's
and that's still minor to the grand
scheme of what we're really talking
about but I just think about that like
if this game is is going to be throwing
loot crate's so often for for in Frank
Lee an impressionable like kid like
that's that's scary to me that's like
that's why I was
again it's when I say legendary creates
its because if they do that and they're
like guaranteed one legendary card dude
think about that mindset yeah that's
again oh that's great
how often like doing it legendary cards
well I can only get it like that's what
you're that's the end game right is you
want legendary cards on all your [ __ ]
that you like meaning you have to own
the only we can get one is if I open up
a crate like if they are guaranteeing
one with I'm not saying they are doing
this but that's what's gonna set me over
it's like screw that I don't want to
have to like keep thinking about that
and and get killed by a guy with three
legendary cards on like day two in the
bottom line issue is that this just
supersedes the game its itself it sounds
like this is this is the thing that
stands out to you this may to win is
Peter Wynn and the fact that the
something the gameplay isn't good enough
but it's that EA is focusing much more
on this system than actually just
providing a good game to people it's
manipulation the gambling part is the
game right gambling part is the game
yeah because that's a bunch of people to
YouTube chatter saying why don't they
just file a complaint saying it's
gambling as of so Jason Schreyer over at
Kotaku today at noon was that today he
spoke to the ESRB and they say they
don't see loot boxes as gambling
they said the statement reads ESRB does
not consider loot boxes to be gambling
they told Kotaku while there's an
element of chance in these mechanics the
player is always italics guaranteed to
receive in-game content parenthesis even
if the player unfortunately received
something they don't want allah
duplicates or something that they didn't
know they were gonna get maybe like a
skin they didn't want or a gun they
didn't want ability they want we think
of it as a similar principle tickle
collectible card games like Pokemon
sometimes you local if I open a pack and
get a brand new holographic card you've
had your eye on for a while but other
times you'll end up with a pack of cards
you already have so it's not gambling
because you're unlike a slot machine
you're always guaranteed to get
something but you do know when you're
buying a pack of cards the chances of
finding something rare yeah I think in
situations like this they should at
least give stats like you will get
imaginary 50 boxes right you have a 1 in
20 chance something like that what I can
because at what point is it what point
does it go from undesirable outcome but
not gambling to a loss because it feels
like the difference between gambling and
loot boxes according to this definition
is
that you have a net gain according to
your definition but like doop-doop is
not getting to a player correct so like
at what point does from a business
standpoint you still got a product yeah
exactly so like at what point does it
does it bridge the gap I mean like I
think you're right in that if they
provide it some sort of like percentage
or statistic to say like here's the
likelihood of getting something out of
the spot you would know then you
wouldn't have to sit there could be an
informed gambler yeah I know that idea
like you sort of get like overwhelmed
with the the hope in like maybe I'll get
something right like I sitting Lee found
myself
last Saturday bored after playing
destiny for a few hours not getting what
I wanted that I actually paid money to
get some silver to buy something from
ever versus yeah I did that once I did
that I got [ __ ] and I was like whoa what
what came over me like and then I was
thinking the flip side like and if I had
gotten something we better just
reinforce the behavior for me and what
am I actually getting do I actually care
about this do I even care about destiny
I rot it robs the game of its own
identity and your your relationship to
it again like I I kind of think that
what they were doing with this beta was
just to test the waters with like
balancing in that respect meaning like
because I'm again like it's it's again
what you're getting in these crates
right like like I can't tell you the
amount of times I got I go a goddamn
stormtrooper pose from this to like this
like two of those doors are in there to
begin with
I know shirt shows how they're diluting
it right donar stand things or they're
purposely trying just to screw us and
and here's nothing to is that like we're
I mean they turn let this function off
which is weird to me because I would
like to see how that system works is
getting dupes
I got dupes probably six times but I was
not able to Isiah had said to convert
them into crafting parts hmm because
again like a big part of that
frustration that I was having was that
like I wasn't getting enough crafting
parts right it was that was taking way
too slow that I need that will be
balanced I would imagine that they're
gonna like dial back a little bit and
make things more constructive again with
like more classifications of like
a star fighter you know bomber crate
that's more specific like they'll have
maybe more of those to like ease that
like people complain about progression
but but it sucks that that is the
fulcrum for whether or not you like this
game is how right they you decide to
banish it right and after the game comes
out and if it doesn't sell that they can
then range it that that's [ __ ]
it is far been jank on our YouTube chat
would just brought up a good point in
China Blizzard had to start disclosing
loot crate probability drops which those
are all aesthetic that's nothing like
Battlefront 2 which is abilities and
everything China means right China was
saying that it's because of gambling
laws they had to disclose drop hub
probabilities and if the ESRB were to
classify microtransactions as gambling
these publishers or develop publishers
would have to make these games
adults-only which would cut out all of
their sales because you can't sell it to
only games and retail stores from well
in like Game Stop and Best Buy at Target
they would lose all their sales hence
they would get rid of micro trains they
could also just put in a progression
model that is clear to the player that
doesn't revolve around random jobs and
just tell you the [ __ ] you want for the
money that you're gonna pay for it up
front like you don't have to have this
sort of like vague intermediary word it
must be just random thing
let me progress and if that's not fast
enough for me sure I'll throw you money
if I really want to I want to be that
guy just strip out the randomness of it
the randomness is the problem it's fine
a lot of free to play game right because
this is where this all started I would
say it back with like mobile games
became big free play but that's but that
time is money man like right I don't
know that it's okay no no but back with
free to place feel like they're taking
that model which pretty much you just
have the choice to spend more time to
unlock these things or spend money which
that plays off of your the time you want
to spend whereas these games were paying
$60 already right that design yes it
goes without saying that's the huge
problem with it but then it becomes a
problem because so I was looking I was
curious because I know with mobile games
the free-to-play games make most of
their money off like a select few whales
yeah people who spend a ton of money
whereas most people won't spend anything
according to statistics so I was curious
about how much money micro transactions
actually make and I didn't find a lot of
figures because my in my head I was like
at what point is the bad press gonna
deter publishers from even implementing
these because I don't want to sound
sappy but my heart does break for
developers like
have to assume monolith was not super on
board with these microtransactions yeah
the people making multiple I have to
imagine it wasn't their decision it must
have come down from the maps and stuff
exactly so to clarify before to seven
they changed their like how you were in
credits it used to be you could spend
like X dollars a year to be part of the
premium Club which he would get plus 100
percent credits earned all the time now
you get 25 like burner cards to do that
essentially if you pay that premium
price also you used to be able to like
change around your mods they're called
mods like you would you could drive at
night for extra credits right now those
are also burner cards you get randomly
so one day you'll get like drive at
night for extra credits the next day
you'll get like drive this specific
course or in it's all random so then you
can't like you don't know what you're
gonna have to do to get the money it's
not clear it's not transparent it's not
like people plant paying the premium
price whereas they used to just have a
set plus 100% experienced credit bonus
now it's 25 one-time used cards my
question and a lot of people are at what
point are you or Warner Brothers or
Microsoft gonna start saying the bad
press isn't worth it because this is a
great game without it so I looked up
like the price point that these
microtransactions make and you the
biggest figure I found as of last fall
and November I believe was I want to ask
you guys you might see it right now oh
sorry no no it's fine ultimate team
across FIFA Madden and NHL to last
year's titles how much do you think MIT
team being the main microtransaction
focal point where people can pay for
certain players and increase their team
you don't have to pay but it again
expedites the process in a game you
already paid $60 for how much do you
think those three games made for EA and
microtransactions Cali ballpark I'm so
bad at this no you're fine it's curious
like what other people's perception is
the whole year well I really give a
little contrary a made about like 2.3
billion in all like revenue last year
how much of that was ultimate team micro
transaction
purchases a 300,000 okay do you see it
okay but yes but I have a follow-up
question okay
guess how much Activision made last year
wait hold on let me tell ya so you said
three hundred thousand six hundred fifty
million what team along that's not
counting so now he is putting this stuff
on Battlefront two dozen people look
that much money into that and again I
don't like they not many people disclose
now not many people disclose their their
figures but as of last year that's what
EA said on an earnings call the CEO
Jorgenson is that last name Jurgens okay
no no 650 million is ultimate team
specifically ultimate team my triple
microtransactions that's not counting
any number of other ways you can spend
money through a to give EA and
microtransactions alright
Activision what games like what just a
lizard blizzard stuff lizard call duty
call duty Skylanders sure I don't know
if Skylanders counts as
microtransactions people are buying the
toys that's part of that platform
building a solid bill you got I would
say 1 billion and $1 mmm I'll do a
billion minus 3.6 billion dollars oh ok
so a lot of that like I can see that I
guess now that I think about it like
Blizzard like I've been tempted to buy
crates before did Mass Effect Andromeda
have these because that's like an early
example I can think of Mass Effect 3 had
random loot crate's but the difference
being there although it might have
sparked this kind of unfortunate trend
that was a co-op mode in Mass Effect 3
so it wasn't like Battlefront 2 where
you're playing against other people who
could be spending money or maybe not
that was co-op mode so if someone else
spent more money they're still on your
team fighting off these aliens with you
so that wasn't much a problem and I
actually probably spent maybe like 50
bucks getting those because that was the
first instance that and I think that's
the last time I've ever spent how you
guys do you actually I'm curious like
I'm not gonna shame you but have you
spent money on micro transactions ever
before
yeah I had before I ever watch in Mass
Effect 3 for me over watch like for
specific I was trying to get like
Halloween Christmas
to be colony costumes to be completely
honest I I will do it just to see like
I'm sorry I will do it once like destiny
was example was like I just want to see
what it is Valen I don't know but let's
see I know I like to think it's like
part of her in my mind in my mind I'm
like it's part of the job like I just
want to know like what I'm getting into
well I mean I justified because we got
the game for free and it's like well I
didn't yeah that's another thing is like
the money I spend on games is part far
different than like the average person
who spends money on games which is why I
have no concept of how much people like
the fraction of their total profits for
like whatever Altima team also I don't
care out sports with her that is just
like I'm still reeling about that is so
much money I mean and that's yeah that's
not even considering what they had
battlefield one last year as well hey I
know like the fraction of their total
profits from all of those games this was
just ultimate team one mode across three
oh my god 3.6 billion dollars that's
more revenue than EA has generate Grand
Theft Auto oh sure that's a huge one
yeah hundred dollars right but start
card that's it's been over five years
but those aren't random eyes you know
what you're getting right or do you I'm
actually asking you're legit putting
money into a different currency to buy
like a new vehicle new vehicles
literally everything but you have you
have the choice over what you're
actually putting the money toward right
on GTA online they're with you I'm sure
that makes a ton of money it's I mean
it's you heard all their earnings and
why like it's like you know someone
looked like a release window for for
Rockstar Games right right for it's been
a while since I've made a gamer as much
like crazy money as GTA 5 made they
don't need to make another thought for
how long GTA online I'm sure Red Dead
Redemption 2 will have that gangs and
robbers here's a random artists prey
be careful there's quicksand like yo s
chickens first I do want to say that
that is a less egregious model than the
buying a random drop yeah thing and
destiny in the ever verse case for
destiny like you can still get a bright
and gram through play yeah sure so like
I don't have a problem with it's like so
tied to the progression right like I
wanted to just circle back on that yeah
yeah but I will say that I the like I
spend I've spent money on mobile games
where like it's the same thing where
you're buying a separate currency but
you know what you're putting that money
into right like Fire Emblem heroes or I
was really gonna ghost like Sailor Moon
match three or I spent money but like
the most egregious example was though I
think it was the game that like set set
off like the upper the upper or for the
App Store for iOS was the kid was
playing like a totally heavy-handed like
this is a children's game and he was
able to like in the game was a button
was like buy more points with [ __ ] my
mom was like what how did you do that so
easily I showed my mom candy crush like
a while back like when it first came out
and she got really into it cuz my mom
really likes those kinds of games and
she spent like I think ten dollars on
the game or something my dad was so mad
he was like this is so stupid why'd you
do this and she was like you spent 60
dollars on a new Call of Duty every year
so I can spend $10 on candy Christmas
man I was like Kathy Kathy okay that
makes sense but I mean like just going
back to the the difference between like
spending money on a currency where you
can then buy the thing that you are
looking for specifically versat and also
that was a game that was free to play so
it's a little a little different uh
microtransactions are like going to Taco
Bell with $10 giving it to them and
saying I hope I get a crunch Ravan and
they just give you a gordita crunch or
something exactly egg bullsh that's the
best the [ __ ] part then that's a
great and then on the comparison you can
free if you don't mind going over that
that cow over there and begin the
process of making your own cheese
all of this yourself there's a farm in
the back it's gonna take about four
months to grow the beans I went to Taco
Bell and they said hey you can have a
Crunchwrap you can either make it
yourself or you can pay $3 like that's
fair but if I give them five bucks and
they're like we don't know we're gonna
give you they just give me six bags of
cinnamon twist just my wanted to maybe
we could end it on this part of this
talk is Jesus I'm taking so long say you
were you brought up like yeah you yeah
you you brought up like the balancing
right of like okay now going back to
these crafting parts right someone I was
going through a bunch of like a threat
threads with people like tackling and
complaining about this it is it's a
really disgusting system right now for
this battlefront beta some did the math
was like okay if every loot crate you
got like 15 crafting parts by chance
which that doesn't even happen like it's
that's but if it were the case if it
were guarantees and you wanted to buy
and upgrade every gun in battlefront
which is two weapons just to just in the
beta yeah for each class like how long
you think that would think someone did
the math 300 hours it's like three
thousand hours three thousand hours to
not spend money on that game that's just
pretty sure that's its number that's
just from the beta so it's it's over a
thousand I know that much I swear oh god
it's ridiculous so the point the point
is that there's no way that that as of
the beta like that balancing is gonna be
in play I I cannot fathom that number
that rate of which you get crafting
parts to be the case but it's
interesting and you brought up Peter
which is like I have I just it's just a
weird feeling of just like they the beta
like the people - they are the puppet
masters yes like they went to like the
gross spectrum of beta and like I wonder
if it was like intentionally alright
intentionally just like stirred all this
all this like frustrate this frustration
in like
yeah just so the gross just so that the
the changes that are made are like so
significant oh good job you know what if
you know I'm getting out oh yes like
like they it's like they wanted to see
the reaction and what if there wasn't
what if there wasn't any reaction sure
and they're like oh damn we don't know
they make they make keep it the way it
is they might they might do that they
might do that oh the graduating thing
because I really I think that's things
we haven't talked about the positive
qualities of this game like you did and
like Mike brought that up like I feel so
bad for the people I mean cuz like you
can criticize as a developer or a
publisher but like the individual people
who put in work I always feel for those
people it just sucks
yeah like it's it's it's pretty fun to
play it but like these things are just
so looming allophones who seems fun at
its most basic level
well maybe not most basic level but
apart from the microtransactions again
according to our review and a bunch of
you around the office and the Internet
in general shadow war is a very fun game
it's it's ambitious as hell and I do
feel bad that I'm sure monolith can't
talk because if they a I'm sure they're
contractually obligated they can't say
anything about Warner Bros again this is
all just assumptions assuming Warner
Bros push down this dictum on them
contractually also they can't really
bite the hand that feeds as the
publisher so it sucks but you know they
were they were adamant about saying they
went through the game to make sure it's
perfectly balanced without loot crate's
and then that always begs the question
like so doesn't adding new crates
imbalance it or I don't know like it
just perturbs something that was it was
serene right yeah it's like front of
rocking upon it up so Dave on Twitter
her name is Dave but his handle is the
upshot Canada he says ESRB says loot
boxes aren't gambling what do you what
say you I would say like I think as
maybe to an outside business sense in
the traditional sense it's not gambling
but then like two people who spend a lot
of money and you know
only mentally monetarily for people who
are playing games regularly or even just
playing you play destiny to all year
it's still gonna be gambling if you're
doing a verse that's fun I mean I would
be interested to see the the
physiological response like a comparison
between getting a loot crate or you know
getting like a drop that you worked for
in destiny and like just gambling and I
guess you know I would love to see I'm
sure they've done Studies on this I know
they they had in the past
with like the reactions people get from
from really addictive games I had a
friend who told me something about like
The Sims when I was like oh the Sims
makes you feel like you're on cocaine
addicting to describe anything about a
video game in a review because it sends
this weird message
first of all addicting is a stupid word
and you should say addictive but also
not a good descriptor I mean I would be
really interested to see the
similarities but I mean just from my gut
instinctive ambling I there's I don't
know if I ever like explained also like
how these star cards work and feel like
again these are damage boosters
increased health like it would when I
when I was playing on the stream I'd
been using a wing a lot earlier and I
was like I like I thing like the other
one better bad fighter and then I'm
streaming most like Dave mailings like
I'm rocking right now it's fast nimble
but like firepower I'm taking down guys
quick and that's because and I hope
after train I let I looked at the start
cards I was like oh that's interesting
because I forgot I put on two star cards
that were like epic one was longer
longer cooldown
I don't know I was shortness and I short
or cooldown overheating increased time
or before over magazine yes in like like
a double fire rate and yeah and I took
then I took them off and like notice
that like yeah oh yeah
this is hard to like yeah take down guys
and now there's another factor to where
it's like yeah I also have to level up
these these ranks in order to like
unlock the ability to put a start card
on that I still haven't gotten my third
one and I put 15 hours into the game
already I haven't gone my third ability
to put a star card on an a wing yeah and
I like like you said at the beginning I
like that you were trying to be
optimistic but I don't think this is
gonna change before November
this kind of system sucks because this
game not you know streams that we would
want it to be yeah like it's it's
intricate it's integral now to like
their whole system like with that
getting cards and that's where all these
abilities are get do too soon it's just
gonna be this thing right this is gonna
be another sitting setting off point
where it's like hi if I die and I see
okay the TIE fighter fly by you know I
kill cam and it says oh what did he have
three legendary cards and I just started
the game that's hide that TIE fighter
just had a lights
[Laughter]
[Music]